protesters are gathering on the streets
of the thai capital
bangkok as lawmakers vote on possible
reforms
to the constitution the rally comes a
day after the most violent clashes
between police and demonstrators
since july police used tear gas and
water cannons to drive backgrounds
dozens were injured including six people
who were hit by gunshots bangkok has
seen months of youth-led
rallies calling for changes to the
constitution and
most controversially reforms to
thailand's monarchy
let's cross over to bangkok where
journalist philip sherbal has been
following this story for us protesters
have returned to the streets today
you've talked to him i understand uh
what are they saying
yeah they really want to um make a point
they were gathering outside parliament
yesterday where
mps have been considering possible
changes to the constitution
and um the the this is one of the core
demands of the protesters
um that those protests yesterday ended
in some fairly nasty clashes um
and um they uh really want to sort of
return to the streets now make clear
that they're not being cowed
and also there is talk that they may
march on the police headquarters the
police are certainly
expecting that and they've um barricaded
themselves in
um using trucks and razor wire to sort
of blockade the gates and warn that
they'll be very decisive action against
protesters if they do try
to make a move there it's not clear if
the protesters will do that or if
they're actually
trying to fool the police and might have
another destination as their ultimate
end because they have been
known to do that in previous weeks as
well
and while we're looking at live pictures
uh of that
protest going on what can you tell us
about the constitutional
constitutional amendments that are
currently being voted on
yes well um so the parliament has been
sitting yesterday and
mps have been and senators have been
voting today on a series of
possible amendments to the constitution
now
the constitution was drafted by the
military under the old junta
and um basically enshrines the sort of
role of the monarchy in key positions in
the in the country and
um indeed of the military-backed elite
and the
uh protesters have been insistent that
if you're gonna have change in thailand
change from the top
then you have to rewrite this
constitution now the versions that are
being voted on today
run the gamut from very minor tweaks to
um
to major changes but it does seem that
the mps and senators it's a complicated
process of voting for different
amendments
are going to back perhaps not
surprisingly because they are the
government majority
some very sort of conservative
amendments that would only essentially
establish a drafting committee to look
at possible changes down the road
the students and the protesters will be
very unhappy with that and that
they told me today if those votes are
confirmed while they're out in the
streets they're going to make that
um central to what they're doing today
in terms of their messaging
and in terms of their um and the
demonstrations so what about the
changes to the monarchy that
demonstrators
want and are they likely to to get it
uh the answer to that is are they they
probably aren't they're facing a huge
uphill challenge
um the the constitution the early
clauses of it this this military-drafted
constitution
do enshrine the um the monarchy's power
um to sort of to govern in key regards
um the
the king also has assumed powers
since he became the monarch in 2016 over
key elements of the budget and over key
military appointments
the students um insist this has to
change that thailand
uh that this is not the constitutional
monarchy that thailand um
is on paper they say in practice um
the power of the royal family is way too
strong but they're up against the royal
family the military that backs them
um and big businesses that sort of
support the
current um the current establishment so
you know they are um they're up against
very strong vested interests and to
achieve change on that front would be a
major breakthrough but
they're determined to show on the
streets that they have the energy and
the
um the momentum to keep this going
journalist philip
sherbal reporting for us from bangkok in
thailand thank you
thank you